as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and you
had people and i'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals and
thugs
including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists
and other hate groups that are repugnant
to everything we hold dear as americans
as he refused to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups in one
voice our nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy
these sinister ideologies must be
defeated
hate has no place in america if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell